I have a lot of stuff going on in my
life like that I'd go thank you heroin
like eliminates a lot of the emotions
for me so I don't have to feel it like
my daughter being gone is one of the big
big problems right now for me and it
really messed me up in the head really
took her so like that's why he was like
that because it just I don't have to
feel it was feeling anything okay camera
so I plan your XD room on the sidewalk
this morning yeah we're just leave last
night mainly a moment I have a friend
nose department down here bit Simon's
too sure person right now kind of stay
outside so I don't miss him can't miss
any second oh they're just a clogged
pipe a mother in Toronto where you're
from San Obispo mm-hmm which is central
supposed to talk yeah the Central Coast
yes where I was radians is out there
yeah I was around on the East Coast for
the past like I've been here for four
years but before that I was on the East
Coast for biting ears where we doing
back there just moving around working
and stuff like that what kind of work
have you done I Eve done anything from
retail to working for rides and
commercials in New York City stuff like
that you're just kind of bounced around
jobs I kind of know a little bit
everything that's my place what age did
you start doing girls I think I started
long
[Music]
he's just smoked weed a lot like though
that's not already 3d but I didn't
really like dabble in like the harder
stuff until he it's about 19 or 20 yeah
and then I took a break of it for a long
time I ended up having a kid and she's
six no where she she she oh she was
taken from me like two years ago CPS
probably took her for me the state take
her where yeah over some ridiculously
they weren't supposed to take her but
they weren't gonna listen to me so yeah
but I haven't seen her in about two
years
yeah I miss her but I'm thinking all
that stuff out now I just I got carried
away with a lot of stuff and messed up
and I know he did though at least I'm
under now of is yeah I'm working on a
lot of stuff right now yeah yeah it is I
got likes everyone
yeah been down here a lot of the girls
are getting into prostitution just like
yeah they're there's quite a handful of
them that's pretty dumb actually yeah
no I can't bring myself to do it I don't
know I've had people either think I do
it or have offered for me to do tonight
I can't bring myself to do it though but
it's not just for like watching what
happens to these other girls down here
it makes me really sad but I mean that's
their hustle you know I respect the
night but I would they do but yeah yeah
that's true
I mean I've never really good past
myself to try getting that through
whatever we were to see yourself in five
years five years probably living out in
the Bay Area because I like it a lot of
there only because I do LR and I mean I
do tattooing ahead you pain so that's
like you might get away from me all this
and the stress and stuff so I think
that's where I like to see myself in
five years I didn't and I don't do it so
I want to try really hard
starting now like this year to get to
there yeah yeah yeah just it's not a
happy place I don't know every time I
come down here and Beasley cos puts me
in such a buffer mood every time I want
to hear this
it's it's hard for me I'd have to deal
about like that that's why it just helps
but it's something that I'm trying to
look past like I'm avenging a certain
program I think I might looking into
more I did this month like a couple
weeks ago I looked into programs but I
think I'm gonna start really like moving
towards not just looking at new like
maybe like getting into one like I
wouldn't mind doing it like an intensive
outpatient treatment just because I know
I have other [ __ ] to do I can't just
stay indoors and like be there locked up
to get clean like I couldn't do anything
nuts I'd have to be able to go and do
other things and stage me like it's kind
of like a willpower type of thing like
huh I'd feel more accomplished if I was
able to like maintain me being sober and
being able to do stuff on the outside
you know I mean sometimes the pole must
be so strong you just can't
sometimes you can't resist
yeah but that's when it all comes down
to whether like you know you can really
do it or you can't think and obviously
I've gotten clean before and I went
without it for you like almost 12 years
and I did it by myself I didn't need
help from you know a patient treatment
center you know a doctor I just did it
myself like you know that first month
was held like I suffered for it but you
know I put myself there like nothing
ever like drugs that good if you think
they're that good like nothing that good
is ever gonna come without a price like
whether it's going through withdrawal
and like feeling all that like that's
the price you have to pay if you're
gonna you know mess around everything
yeah that's everything for sure but
especially for drugs like that the
consequences are there you just have to
know whether you can handle it or not
you know that's that's how I see it at
least I don't know but I know you can do
it it's just a matter of me just
conjuring up the strength to get out
there and just do it and stop making
excuses for myself why I shouldn't do it
like that's the only thing I'm working
on right now but I've come a long way so
I'm getting a lot better
good luck thank you thank you talking
you know thank you thank you for talking
to me that actually made me feel better
this morning
I've been standing it off frustrated
with funding all this stuff